i've seen the first six episodes of the
series
i love it i love it so much i cannot
wait to see
where this thing is going this is a
fantastic series so um and that's it i'm
out hey guys
that was easy exactly how much did aaron
tell you once you
landed the role how much did he explain
about the full arc
of your characters and how much was he
sort of like script by script you were
finding things out
uh yeah you didn't share much i think uh
i know nate did you know much uh travis
no
i didn't i uh no cause i
no it was basically kind of like where
the where the story
had uh had started with these two these
two characters
soon marcus and there were certain
secrets of i think sue's past that he
had shared with me
that they were secrets that i wasn't to
tell anyone else
which was kind of fun well one of the
things that i love about the series is
that each episode
you find out more and more about the
world about these characters about the
back stories it keeps you very
invested uh what was it like for you
guys reading these scripts for the first
time because
each one is loaded with stuff
yeah it's a very com complex series and
um
and i think you're going to love the
last four because it you get answers and
then you get
a lot more questions as well which is
every time you get an answer then
there's another question to um
get an answer for it and i think that's
very compelling for the audience and
it makes a show um you know it's great
when somebody talks about a show after
they watch it with their friends and
that stuff and obviously visually it's
just
ridley scott so it's just absolutely
ridiculous
never seen anything on tv like it
oh and there's other than ridley stuff
there's nothing there's no movies
that can um hold up to the look of the
show either
that's another thing i want to talk
about the production design of
the series and and what you guys put on
screen
it looks like a movie every episode um i
am curious what is it like
or what was it like for you guys
stepping on set for the first time was
there a particular set that you were
just like
jaw on ground we shot in south africa so
i was
blown away from the the actual south
african landscape and that
that's why i really wanted to shoot
there because it's um
a lot of that place is unseen and then
obviously ridley adds his own
touches to stuff and just really brings
it to life but um
it was a gorgeous country that we yeah
locations that we
we shot at walking around inside the ark
that they created
within the studio was was really cool
because it was just reminding me of
just alien and ripley uh
yeah there was like there's definitely i
feel like visually there's a lot of
aesthetical
crossovers with aliens so i was
i was just loving it one of the things
i've heard about ridley
is that he works incredibly fast um
did you have that experience with ridley
because he's created visually this world
like it's like the actor's playground uh
he doesn't over talk scenes he trusts
that what you're
that you know that you know what it is
that you're gonna do in the scenes it's
just that he's just working out how he's
going to capture that
um so yeah i remember like we did
my first day and we did this the scene
but it was like we shot it twice
and before like before they had kind of
asked i was like do you want to go again
it's like
no it's good we have like he's literally
moving on to the next set and it's
the idea that like you know he just
knows he's he's got like you know
60 years experience of of filmmaking so
he knows
exactly how to capture something and
tell a story what is it like though
because i've heard he does like two
takes maybe three
what is it like as an actor knowing you
you really gotta do it
on these first two takes you know what i
mean i think you're gonna bring are you
bring
like he knows it's like he's not gonna
overwork the scene so
essentially he feels that i feel like he
feels like what you're going to do in
the first two takes is going to be
what's right travis i am curious though
uh
after vikings you had a lot of
experience working on vikings for a
number of years
how does making this series maybe
compared to what it was like making
vikings
and i'm also curious uh about signing on
for another
series was it something that you were
looking to do no it's definitely
something i wasn't
looking to do and my choice was all
based on ridley
you know the work with ridley scott and
um
and free food and for damn
no like i said i i'm not sure if i said
to you or somebody else but i signed on
without reading the script just because
it was ridley scott and um
and i wanted to spend some time in south
africa too and i wanted to
meet one of my idols neve
[Laughter]
it all came true i was going to say how
much did you end up paying to work with
ridley
yeah yeah no exactly exactly it was like
that though
but um and he's just a great humble
fellow and
and his energy is amazing too he's 80
i'm not sure 83 or 82.
he's like a like a 20 year old you know
he's got so much energy and doesn't stop
thinking and um he just is
you're pretty lucky to be able to spend
time with him and work with him
and uh a really great guy so yeah
extremely lucky they always say that uh
on
on movies and series uh not to work with
kids and not to work with animals
uh the series has a lot of kids
so we got to work with both but the kids
were um
the kids are amazing we said that in a
different i
really enjoyed working with the kids and
my favorite thing there's a lot less
drama with the kids and
and just they just make you laugh when
they get bored they make you laugh
and when they're um when they're hungry
and don't want to act anymore
makes you laugh and uh but they're all
great kids and
and a long way from home and um
and did we we didn't i don't think we
had any animals we had
we did with a mouse oh we did have all
that's amazing
it's so funny because felix felix
jameson who plays
arizona who's he's an extraordinary
little talent but yeah
he he is scared of mice so he had to he
had his mouth for every scene
that kept on peeing on him uh
yeah you yeah yeah the kids are great
all of the kids are great
um i actually agree i thought all the
kid performed all the
children if you will all the
performances were like fantastic
everyone
really you buy into it because everyone
is selling what they're doing
yeah you know if you could um you guys
worked on a ton of cool sets the the
sets on this thing were incredible
which is um is there one that if you
could like keep a set
you know in your backyard which is the
one that you would actually keep
the main location we shot at most of the
time was just
location and when it rained there'd be
waterfalls along the rock faces
and all that stuff which i think they
actually i'm not sure but i think a lot
of it they were taking that out because
it's meant to look a lot more arid
but it was a beautiful farm and vineyard
and they had cattle and
yeah i think that's it but all the stuff
really created it just wouldn't go with
my house
or my backyard
oh hey liz i got to stop i'm just going
to say congratulations
can't wait to continue watching and good
luck with the rest of the speed dating
thank you good to see you again right